>>Karimah: My name is Karimah.
I graduated last year and I'm first
in my family to go to college.
>>Karimah: Growing up, I was always
scared that college was not going
to be an option for me, not
only because of financial needs,
but because of my appearance
and my ethnicity.
My father, he sat down with me and just
told me, "Daddy can't afford college."
I remember feeling really
heartbroken that I was trying so hard.
I was a four point oh student, but I've
always believed that there's a path.
And I remember my sophomore
year at Envision Academy.
I began to blossom into
the person I am today.
>>You know, I'm always big on leadership
and finding myself, and I found myself
through poetry and all the workshops
and projects here at Envision.
>>So when I did get a scholarship,
I remember showing my dad.
I told him, "Well, look Dad, like,
college is not a worry anymore."
Being the first generation in
my family to go to college,
I am a role model for
my younger siblings.
I'm just excited that I have
opened these doors for them.